foreign
[Music]
helped me to land my new role at boots
first later as a senior director with
cab Gemini
I got a reasonable hike in salary hey
I'm Vivek malarka living in Nottingham
UK with my family I spent early years of
my career in India for about 15 years
and became a country head
I really cherish some of my moments
working on projects with let's see apj
Abdul Kalam I moved to the UK in 2012 as
head of Business Development at very
very Miller
later I was recognized by a government
as an exceptional Talent candidate and
soon awarded Talent visa to continue my
career in UK upskilling which simply
learn helped me to land my new role at
boots first later as a senior director
with capgemini and I got a reasonable
hike in salary these certifications have
provided me the world view of business
it has broadened my knowledge which I
think was limited in certain areas
and I'm happy that I went to Simply
learn for my upskill which gave me deep
understanding on the subject and also
attend the live virtual classes which
was not available in most of the
learning platforms enabled me to
clear those interviews the course helped
me to position myself with my
capabilities and hence I also recommend
it to many of my peers age is just a
number when it comes to learning new
skills upskilling empowers to choose
your own path and create your own
destiny